[Musique]
la petite reine à ces petits princes 26
enfants de 8 à 11 ans qui en six jours
vont avaler en vtt 120 km deux mille
mètres de dénivelé de bibracte alésia
entre coups de pédales coup de pompe et
coup de main voici leur histoire
vous allez prendre vos casques et vos
mitaines
c'est le dernier matin de l' aventure en
voisin christophe donne un coup de main
pour la logistique des vélos il y a cinq
ans il faisait lui aussi le bibracte
alésia en tant que parent accompagnateur
une expérience qui crée des liens forts
que ni son fils ni lui ne sont prêts
d'oublier
c'était beau petit bon surtout la
cohésion des enfants de c'est surtout ça
qui nous a marqués plus et depuis sont
restés copa mais pour les participants
de l'édition 2021 l'heure n'est pas
encore au bilan mais aux courbatures
les jambes sont lourdes après 100 km
parcouru tout le monde le pressent le
mental de chacun et l'énergie collective
seront appelés à la rescousse
je pense que ça va être compliqué la
dernière chance pourquoi ça va être
compliqué je suis fatigué c'est dans il
faut pas s'arrêter il faut continuer et
qu'il faut pas descendu et lyon on le
voit progresser bon au niveau du vélo
mais c'est surtout dans la tête tous les
petits blocages de confiance en soi qui
se lève et puis du coup ils se rendent
compte de ce qu'ils sont capables de se
dépasser d'aller au bout d'eux mêmes
donc ça je pense que ça va être
aujourd'hui vraiment l'aboutissement de
de tous les efforts de la semaine qui
vont qui vont se révéler quoi et cette
dernière étape commence très fort avec
une cote à 15%
quant à christian et jean marc qu'on
dise ça va monter la défense inquiète un
peu c'est bien son courage et parce
qu'il ya un sacré circuit reste tout à
fait là c'est pas de cloche à mesure que
les kilomètres défilent le soin se
montre de moins en moins tendre avec les
jeunes mollet
[Musique]
lisons a suivi une crevaison
elle est décroché mais elle peut compter
sur l'entr'aide de ses camarades pour
atteindre le sommet au courage et à sa
lentille et g13 est très rigolo vivement
mon lit ce soir non c'est bien c'est ses
choix typhon effet la série mais
j'aurais fait très très chaud et cette
montée n'était pas évident donc non mais
c'est le cvu content je suis contente
forte heureusement l'itinéraire regorge
aussi de plateau et de descentes et les
organisateurs n'hésitent pas à
multiplier les échappées belles
les cours de sciences et d'histoire
feinte alors discrètement le bout de
leur nez
l'école se fait à ciel ouvert c'est une
capote c'est quoi un pays placé pour que
les vignerons et sabri déjà déjà pour
s'abriter oui cette ultime étape de 20km
touche à sa fin au bout de l'effort
coeur léger jean-pier déroulent elles
les enfants ne soupçonnait pas le comité
d'accueil qui les attendait à alésia
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au début je sais pas trop faire du vélo
fin j'avais un peu peur de cailloux mais
maintenant ça va beaucoup mieux quoi
qu'elles sont à retenir bas aussi
d'avoir fait du vélo un groupe
d'avoir aussi à rencontrer une autre
école plein de bonnes choses mais là je
suis très très fier de lui parce qu'en
plus il n'est pas spécialement sportif
est en fait il s'est carrément dépassé
j'en suis sûr et je suis fier hier je
suis hyper fier de tous ces enfants qui
ont été très courageux très solidaire
c'est une très jolie réussite des
enfants heureux dé des accompagnateurs
qui pleurent des parents comblés
on se dit que l aventure une aventure
immortalisé sous les moustaches de
vercingétorix à alésia le chef gaulois a
été défait par césar des enfants ont
convaincu leurs peurs leurs doutes et
ont gagné des souvenirs impérissables